650 millions d'euros c'est le bilan
matériel provisoire des émeutes 90% des
sinistres sont des professionnels et des
collectivités soit plus du double des
280 millions d'euros anticiper la
semaine dernière les émeutes de 2005
avaient fait moins de dégâts largement
largement elles avaient duré trois
semaines donc ça avait duré longtemps
mais la facture c'était seulement si on
peut dire 200 millions d'euros c'est une
explosion de la sinistralité certains
assureurs peuvent décider dans leur
politique de ne plus assurer certaines
régions certaines localisations précises
les tarifs des primes d'assurance
devraient aussi nettement augmenter
prochainement j'ai été également aligné
des voir que le week-end dernier des
députés insoumis étaient présents à une
manifestation interdite parce que
lorsqu'on vote la loi en semaine on la
respecte le week-end ce sont les dealers
et les imams qui ont sifflé la fin de la
récréation
les dealers
dans les colonnes de en Provence la
députée Renaissance Anne Laurence Petel
qualifié le jeune de 17 ans de
délinquant des propos quelle précise
aujourd'hui je ne l'appelle pas
uniquement le délinquant mais je ne
l'appellerai pas le petit Naël ou l'ange
vous vous amusez avec le ministère de la
carrière vous relayez les vous vous
relayez je dis BFM parce que c'est BFM
carolier les prénoms de les prénoms les
prénoms du ministère de l'Intérieur les
plus répandus dans ces émotiers je n'y
crois pas une seconde je vais vous dire
moi je pense qu'il y a eu 80 90% de
Mohamed et Dali face à l'ampleur de ce
déchaînement de violence votre
gouvernement a choisi de sortir
l'artillerie de carnaval et la matraque
de guignols avec la rédaction d'un flyer
à destination des parents la restriction
des réseaux sociaux ou encore
l'interdiction de la vente de mortier
d'artifice pour le 14 juillet nous avons
un peuple dans le peuple nous avons une
autre civilisation
c'est une guerre civile pour vous bah
c'est une guerre civile parce qu'ils
sont administrat français vous
n'attendez jamais pour commenter pour
généraliser pour calomnier pour faire de
la petite politique monsieur le député
et c'est à ça qu'on vous reconnaît à
peine arrivé à Vilnius Emmanuel Macron
renforce le soutien de la France à
l'Ukraine nous avons décidé de livrer de
nouveaux missiles permettant des frappes
dans la profondeur à l'Ukraine ce sera
donc déployer conformément aux
engagements que nous avons pris avec eux
vous demandez des efforts de mixité
sociale aux établissements scolaires
privés et vous avez sans doute raison
mais vous vous même vos enfants à
l'École alsacienne temple de l'entre-soi
on ne vous entend pas bien monsieur le
ministre il n'y a aucun apaisement
c'était quand même l'objectif des 100
jours la colère sociale elle est énorme
la défiance est profonde pourquoi parce
que penser répondre à cette situation
uniquement par des mesures sécurité et
par du mépris c'est ne pas l'avoir
compris on a toujours autant
d'autoritarisme et autant de mépris de
la part du chef de l'État en revanche
vous démontrez tous vos talents
d'idéologues vous vous placez en arbitre
des élégances de la pensée d'ailleurs
évidemment souvent unique distribués
bons et mauvais points jeter les
annatèmes contre certains médias vous
méprisez ce faisant les journalistes et
des équipes qui travaillent et des
millions et des millions de nos
concitoyens qui les regardent et les
écoutent ne peut être suspect de
complaisance envers pas péniyami ici il
ne fait qu'annoncer une vérité
d'évidence les attaques qu'il subit
depuis non dénué de racisme le confirme
son audace solitaire doit être salué
ai-je invité à boycotter ai-je pointé du
doigt tel journaliste non je n'ai fait
que commenter de manière banale la ligne
politique d'une chaîne de télévision ce
qui est mon droit le plus strict
monsieur le député symbole de la
reconstruction de Notre-Dame de Paris
quelques morceaux de la charpente ont
été hissés dans le ciel pour trouver
leur place sur l'édifice assister à un
tel spectacle forcément sa marque les
esprits en Islande un vol constitué à
une quarantaine de kilomètres de
Reykjavik est entré en éruption hier la
lave a jailli pour la troisième fois en
deux ans pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
dommage ni de conséquences sur le trafic
aérien